hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown at least one
million ukrainians fleeing their homes
seeking refuge in poland and other
western neighbors but many ukrainian
soldiers and civilians are keeping up
their resistance to russia's invasion a
ukrainian citizen in kiev opens up about
what she's experiencing why she stayed
and her nation's determination to
continue fighting
supreme court nominee judge katanji
brown jackson one of the top google
searches during president biden's state
of the union address fox news
contributor and legal scholar jonathan
turley discusses her judicial background
and why the president may have chosen
her plus commentary by opinion editor
for the washington times charlie hurt
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we take a deeper look at
the stories important to you you can
subscribe on your favorite podcast
player by going to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm charles payne i'm kat timf i'm
stuart varney and this is the fox news
rundown
friday march 4th 2022 i'm jessica
rosenthal as russia moves into ukraine
and images surface of bombed out homes
and apartment buildings the number of
refugees continues to climb as other
ukrainians vow to stay and fight we
don't know what we will be tomorrow i'm
chris foster judge katanji jackson
brown's been meeting with senators the
head of supreme court confirmation
hearings this month well we know she's
very methodical uh she's obviously
you know very talented she's
a lot of people think the world of her
but we really don't have much in terms
of judicial philosophy
and i'm charlie hurt i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
images of bombed out condo complexes and
apartment buildings are filling social
media as the mayor of an area called
kersan said russia has taken over
successfully it's just north of crimea
which russia took over in 2014. it's
like a hell
we don't know what to do that's why we
cross
to another country more than a million
ukrainians have fled becoming refugees
the international criminal court says
they've launched an investigation into
whether russian officials are committing
war crimes this week secretary of state
anthony blinken announced additional
sanctions on russia's defense sector
saying they are focused on all of
russia's actions we're taking account of
it we're documenting it
and we want to ensure among other things
that there's accountability for it
thursday the treasury department
announced new sanctions on dozens of
russian oligarchs president biden said
ahead of a cabinet meeting thursday that
that included one of russia's wealthiest
billionaires and i'm
banning travel to america by
by more than
50 russian oligarchs their families and
their close associates earlier this week
ukraine's president vladimir zelinsky
said this our army is doing everything
to fully break the enemy nearly nine
thousand russians have been killed in
one week ukraine doesn't want to be
covered by the dead bodies of soldiers
go home fox's own trey yingst and kiev
was invited to meet with zielinski this
week with other foreign members of the
press he said that while they want
additional support they are thankful for
the support they've received to date
while many have left ukraine zielinski
has not and neither have many civilians
who are staying behind to fight or help
in whatever way they can i stay in a
city center in the downtown
and i can hear explosions and
all kinds of noises of war zena kokina
lives and works in ukraine's capital and
we have sirens all the time which
when we hear it we need to go to shelter
and they warn the population about the
danger
of the rockets or of the attacks and in
the city center there were
several cases of bombing during the week
and we
have the explosions all the time
in different parts of the city and
suburbans are
really
attacked
by the enemy but we never know
where the attack will
come and you said the suburban areas
outside of kiev are being attacked
yeah the suburbs they suffered most of
all
the whole day today i was trying to get
out my friends from those parts of the
city because the buildings are ruined
there are a lot of families in the
shelters who can't get out of them now
and they don't know whom to address and
how to get out of those parts of the
city because there is no
systematic help
we have a lot of volunteers and
territory defense and troops but
they can't get out of the shelters at
the moment and after bombing there are a
lot of
suffered families so the suburbans
suffered most of all for the moment
we saw pictures of like what you were
talking about like condo buildings
apartment buildings
that were bombed out like in um
borodienka i think is one place and um
another village called gorenka also
outside of kiev when you hear the
explosions and you see
the images of these bombed out buildings
i mean how how worried are you as you
sit in kiev that the russians are just
coming closer and closer to where you
are
it's a very interesting feeling because
even though it's been a week since the
beginning of the
war
but we still can't believe that it's a
reality
it's a total mess i i even can't find
the words to describe it because none of
us previously seen a war by our own eyes
and it's really frightening
i'm sure xena why did you decide to stay
and give
this is the question i'm asked every
single day by many people
and the only answer i have is that it's
my home
i assume you don't have children if you
had children would you be be leaving
would your situation be
maybe i think that if i have children i
would think about them firstly
but i have parents who are now in
another ukrainian city which is also
preparing for the attack and my parents
i was asking them to leave but they
refused they also stay in their hometown
and i understand well i'm a young person
who can live anywhere in europe or
anywhere else in the world i speak
english i can work anywhere
but for the moment i understand that i
can help here because this is the moment
when
my people and my country needs the
support and help of people
you know what are you doing to help are
you armed right now do you have a
firearm a gun i mean what are you doing
no
no no i i don't have an arm i can tell
for example for today since morning i
was conducting with
foreign
friends and
organizations that
wants to help ukraine with humanitarian
aid
then i was arranging the food for our
territory defense
and all the things which are done for
those who need help you know
for those who suffered in the suburbans
who need logistics to
get out of those places for those who
need to get in some way to the border so
you know our people now are very active
in helping the state and helping each
other in every single
problem which appears
xena if people did want to leave kiev
could they is it surrounded by russian
troops like could people drive out or
walk out of the city and west still
as of today there is only one one
direction which is free
and people can leave
but well today i got a message from my
friend who
was driving from kiev in northern
direction
they left by car and they were shot
by the tank
and they were shot out by a tank yeah
they were shot out and there were two
families one of which is dead and the
second one is injured and it's not safe
actually there is no
green corridor for those who live
and if you live it's your
responsibility and your
risk to take the road and live in your
own way
you know one family that was injured and
one family that was killed
uh yeah he's the friend of my friends
but today my friend sent me the message
about
this story that they
they were trying to
leave kiev and they got in this trouble
oh my god and you know the first day of
the conflict i had to stay at my friends
in the apartment
but then another family invited us and
in the morning we woke up and it
appeared that the
building where we had to stay
was bombed by the rocket so
it the rocket was flying to the airport
but it missed and it
flew in a building
so
you never know
what is the main target
xena let me talk to you about the
logistics and what's going on in the
ground we've heard that russia has taken
over an area called kirsan i think it's
north of the crimean area
as they move in to take certain parts
obviously this is one sort of large part
how concerned are you when you hear that
the russian army or the russian troops
have taken over
more
of ukraine and how confident are you
right now
in ukraine's army in ukraine's own
military
well as we all understand uh russian is
even more than 10 times bigger than
ukraine with
all its population and its troops and
military capacities despite all the
weapon which was
given to ukraine from europe from all
other countries and international
we're still not secure because
we understand that the
enemy has its goal
and it doesn't want to give it up
so we are not secure at all and we can't
even make any
forecasts because it's unpredictable
actually
we don't know what we will be tomorrow
and
there is the second round of
negotiations but we still don't know
what is the
result and i'm more than confident that
there is no actual result of these
negotiations for the population
xena president zielinski has asked for
more air support and a no-fly zone
it doesn't look like a no-fly zone is
happening anytime soon because i guess
the thinking is that would drag other
countries likely into you know direct
conflict with russia
but do you think it will get to that
point that western countries will end up
being more engaged in this conflict like
what is your sense of the future
and other countries participating
i i don't think that uh the countries
will engage for 100 because it will mean
that it's like a world war if everyone
will take part in a fool in this
conflict so i think
it's a big step for the western world to
be engaged in this conflict in full
it would mean that they take part in the
war
now we have a great support
which it seems to me that it's
unprecedented support from the western
world
but anyway it's
not the
still the conflict between ukraine and
russia
you know one one more question for you
um you referenced it there there was
another round of talks in belarus it
sounds like nothing really concrete has
come out of it but again russia said
ukraine has to declare it will not join
nato
do you want president zielinski to just
do that to just say okay we won't join
nato or do you want ukraine to keep
fighting
if you ask me on the first day of the
confrontation i will
would definitely tell you if i i will
beg
for all this mess to stop because it's
very frightening when you hear
all this bombing outside your street
but now i understand that
we don't have any other way
than to keep fighting because
if we accept the russian conditions it
would mean that
we would become the part of this country
with this government and
with its rules
and i don't think that our president and
our government
is ready after all those
i think
small wins that they already
attained that they are ready to become
the part of russia
xena
um xena thank you so much for your time
we are thinking of everybody there and
we just want you to stay safe
thank you very much i hope this will end
uh
soon and
every one of us will come back to our
normal life and to our plans that we had
before this nightmare
[Music]
this is charlie hurt with your fox news
commentary coming up
confirmation hearings for president
biden's supreme court nominee katanji
jackson brown are scheduled to start
march 21st two weeks from this coming
monday she would fill the seat opening
with judge stephen breyer's retirement
this summer the members of the senate
will decide if i fill your seat
but please know
that i could never
fill your shoes president biden says
judge jackson deserves to be considered
promptly and fairly she cares about
making sure that her democracy works for
the american people
she listens
she looks people in the eye lawyers
defendants victims and families
and she strives to ensure that everyone
understands why she made a decision in
addition to being the first black woman
supreme court justice katanji jackson
would be the first floridian on the
court she grew up in miami went to
harvard and harvard law and clerk for
justice pryor she worked to change
federal sentencing guidelines during the
obama administration was appointed to
the u.s district court for the district
of columbia nine years ago by president
obama and was appointed last year by
president biden to the u.s court of
appeals for the d.c circuit considered
the second most powerful court in the
country so she has experience but not a
thick record of opinions relevant to the
new job the record is long but rather
thin you know the the judge has been on
the court for a number of years
but this is not a nomination coming from
an appellate court jonathan troy is a
fox news contributor a law professor at
george washington university an attorney
and legal scholar and so the vast
majority of these opinions are the type
of opinions you see from trial judges
they resolve rather insular issues
of evidence or outcomes at trial
they're not the type of of decisions
that you can glean a lot about her
judicial
philosophy there are a couple of those
and they go into more depth and she has
a single appellate decision
but we're still a little bit unclear as
to what her judicial philosophy is the
white house and many liberal groups
appear quite confident you know
president biden said that he
wanted someone who would take an
expansive view of unenumerated rights
and these groups have argued for someone
who believes in a sort of living
constitutional approach a very broad
interpretation of the constitution they
seem confident uh that she fits that
model
the problem is that when
the judge came up for her appellate
nomination she was asked whether she
adhered to a living constitution
approach
she refused to answer that question and
said that
it would be inappropriate for her to do
so because she's not allowed to have a
different methodology than the supreme
court
that left all of us rather perplexed
because judges have answered that
question but more importantly
you're required to follow precedent
no one says you can't have your own
judicial
philosophy and then the final reason is
that when she came up as a district
court judge she had no trouble in saying
no to that question so she previously
did answer that question you know that's
going to come up in the confirmation
hearing yeah it sure will uh it used to
be they'd take i don't know a couple
months
to
you know sit down with her to do some
vetting to just get their ducks in a row
um now the senate with the democrats
have you know razor thin
majority they want to get this done as
soon as possible
yeah this is a nascar pace of a
nomination
and you know the the interesting thing
is that the democrats seem quite adamant
that
judge jackson should not get the
confirmation hearing they gave to judge
barrett uh you know judge barrett's uh
confirmation hearing was really
outrageous i mean the democrats
openly insulted her they surrounded her
with
uh with pictures of
people that were that were going to be
victimized if she was confirmed because
they said that she was going she was
being put on the court for the purpose
of striking down the affordable care act
and at the time i i said vociferously
that is completely and absolutely untrue
that the case in front of the supreme
court
had very little chance of overturning
the aca and moreover i thought that she
was more likely to vote to keep the aca
at least in that case that's exactly
what she did
um and well and she was also a victim of
the politics of the time and the timing
of the time with um
with not much left with not much time
left to get her through
so so the democrats obviously wanted to
play that up
well but also the democrats really
crossed the rubicon with judge barrett i
wrote a couple opinions that there was
that the democrats went further than
certainly any modern confirmation i
could think of they demanded that she
say how she would vote on issues like
roe v wade
they stated that they would vote against
her solely because of her judicial
philosophy
and i wrote at the time that they've
created a type of barrett rule uh that
you know it is now appropriate to demand
answers according to that process of how
a a justice was likely to vote on issues
like roe and it was also
stated by
many of the democratic senators that
judicial philosophy alone even if you
are extremely well qualified as was
barrett i would make you ineligible for
confirmation so the question the
democrats now seem to be saying that
would be inappropriate and very good
groups that attack barrett under
judicial philosophy are now insisting
that questions about
jackson's judicial philosophy are really
out of bounds
um three
when she was confirmed last year to the
dc circuit court three republicans
voted for her it was collins markowski
lindsey graham lindsey graham now says
he's a no vote um
he's accusing president biden of being
influenced by the far left i mean
obviously there were there are further
left judges that he could have chosen uh
there are other conservatives who say no
she's a completely reasonable pick
yeah i mean that's what it'll be
interesting about this confirmation
process uh you know the
if they follow the barrett example
they'll be asking her rather pointed
questions about her judicial philosophy
i expect that she will uh again
while not refusing to answer entirely i
think that she's very likely to uh be
limited in what she's uh going to say
uh the
the issue of voting for someone for an
appellate court and then differently on
the before the supreme court is
something that both parties have done
that this is not the first time senators
of both parties have
said that they treat the supreme court
differently
when a nominee comes up because
obviously this is a much more enhanced
uh and lofty position
um is there a process for pro for
practicing um
they hold the candidates hold mock
debates are there mock uh q a sessions
for for supreme court nominees
yeah there are types of murder boards
that are sometimes uh
used the nominees are given
a lot of material by the white house
team it also involves outside counsel
often who volunteer to help a nominee so
these are very practiced answers
and you'll see that i expect that judge
jackson will stay close to the script
does have previous
nominees
the biggest difference is really that
this is coming so soon after the barrett
nomination so there's going to be a lot
of comparisons
barrett did talk about her judicial
philosophy
she talked about how
she has originalist views and how she
approaches the constitution
it was remarkably detailed and frank
uh so
that if that's the comparison you may
have republican senators saying well we
want the same openness from you
because our colleagues said that
judicial philosophy alone can be the
basis to vote against a nominee now part
of the concern for the republicans is
really there's a balancing here right
you've got the first
potential
african-american woman for the court
that has historic meaning it it makes
this a very important historical
confirmation process on the other hand
you don't want to be one of two or three
republicans voting for
a justice if she does prove to be
to the far left
and you know particularly in this
environment uh that could also come back
to haunt you so it's a difficult
position for these senators to be in
yeah it certainly is a little more
fraught no matter no matter what happens
any tough questioning somebody is going
to call somebody a racist
yeah that's right i mean it's it's
already started which is really bizarre
i wrote a piece that said i thought
rather
uncontroversially saying that you know
we have a thin record of actual opinions
when it comes to her judicial philosophy
that seems abundantly obvious you know
she's been a trial judge she has to
follow the precedent of the dc circuit
and the president supreme court so it's
not surprising that we don't have a lot
of opinions to look at i don't know
anyone who's really said that we have a
very good idea of her philosophy what we
know is she's very methodical
she's obviously
you know very talented she's a lot of
people think the world of her but we
really don't have much in terms of
judicial philosophy but that column sort
of triggered this the tsunami from the
left saying you would never ask this of
a male or white nominee which is really
hilarious because if you go back i've
covered almost 30 years
of supreme court nominees and every
single one of them i had this column and
many of them i said we we just don't
have much of a record yeah and i think
it's also you have a nominee who
declined to talk about her judicial
philosophy so it's it's all rather
bizarre but you're going to see that
sort of hair triggered response that you
referred to yeah
she would be the second youngest current
justice behind barrett barrett's 50. uh
judge jackson is 51.
um
any possible dynamic shifts there or is
it really just impossible is that an
impossible question to answer
well you know the nominees are getting
younger and younger you know presidents
are trying to
guarantee their legacy by simple weight
of numbers uh
it's an unfortunate trend quite frankly
um that should not be the overriding
consideration but it is hugely important
now in favor of
judge jackson i will note
that she has many
things in her background that i really
like i mean yes she is young but she has
a lot of years of experience on the
court
i like the fact that she was a trial
judge
that really is an experience that is
fairly
rare on the court i also
really like that she was a public
defender
you know it that that is exceptionally
rare but then finally i like the fact
that she's walked the walk she has
litigation experience it's it's often
the case that
you know when you hear some of the
justices talk it's pretty clear they
haven't done a lot of litigation and a
lot of litigators often complain about
that trial judges complain that the
supreme court seems often out of touch
with the realities of trials so this
that's going to be a nice addition to
the court
jonathan turley i hope you can keep some
time open for us uh
when this thing really gets moving fox
news contributor professor at george
washington university legal scholar
jonathan turley thanks again it's my
great pleasure thank you
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
charlie hurt charlie
what's on your mind welcome to the first
war of the green new deal this is what
happens when rabid environmental zealots
leading our government neuter american
energy and independence and hand global
power over to rapacious tyrants
hell-bent on taking over the world
since president biden's first day in
office he has made it his chief goal to
weaken the united states to the point
that we are now dependent upon russia
for oil the very lifeblood on which the
world still runs
the punishing gas prices you see at the
pump today are not an unfortunate
consequence but the very intentional
purpose of mr biden's policies
if you rely on the only viable form of
transportation in america today then you
deserve to be punished
for true environmental zealots the obama
administration was a failure when he
came into office in 2008 gas prices were
touching four dollars a gallon by the
time he left office eight years later
they were down near two dollars a gallon
primarily because of the boon in natural
gas technologies when mr biden got back
into the white house he and the zealots
around him were determined
not to repeat mr obama's mistakes they
went full jihad on american energy
independence surprising almost no one mr
biden's dangerous anti-american energy
policies led directly to vladimir
putin's invasion of ukraine mr biden's
policies not only weakened america but
they also enriched mr putin and since we
are now reliant upon mr putin's oil for
daily survival the u.s is actually
bankrolling the invasion of ukraine all
in the name of rabid green new deal
environmentalism
the only person who admitted to being
surprised by this tragic turn of events
was mr biden's environmental mullah john
kerry who also happens to be the only
person in washington dumber than mr
biden
as ukrainians were being slaughtered by
russian troops mr kerry was alarmed over
the invasion for other reasons
it could have a profound negative impact
on the climate obviously he groaned
through a faced deadened by too much
botox
you have a war and obviously you're
going to have massive emissions
consequences to the war just when you
thought these people could not get any
dumber the biden administration
dispatched its spokeswoman jen saki to
explain things
oil is the problem she explained on
sunday as hundreds of thousands of
ukrainian women and children fled their
country of the war
she helped enable we need to look at
other ways of having energy in our
country she explained
in other words more windmills fairy dust
and unicorn farts
this may be the world's first green new
deal war but as long as people like jen
saki john kerry and joe biden are
allowed anywhere near our government it
will not be the last
i'm charlie hurt thanks for
you've listening listening to the fox
news rundown stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network my
name is kennedy and welcome to my
podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome it's kennedy saves the world
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes